we're curious how you first met James
Franco first off it was in my freshman
year of Starbucks behind my yeah it's
not me were you a barista or something
like that no what it was he knows this
and he makes fun of that it makes fun of
me for all the time but basically
everyone knew he was going there so I
went there one day just just to see him
but we ended up talking right the
strategic walk by yeah yeah okay
I think all girls have done that oh yeah
yeah and so in terms of the Palo Alto
stories campaign and your role as
co-director on memoria whose idea was
that did he pitch that to you and how
was it presented James mm-hmm well I
think initially it started he definitely
wanted to make a movie out of it so he
asked me just to write like turn some of
his short stories from the book into
short films and he asked a few directors
to do that and then I guess like once
the ball started rolling he like
realized that this can be like something
a lot more fun and exciting if he got
like NYU directors and also gia Coppola
to do it so I think that's how I started
I think mm-hmm and then when did you
meet up with Vlad we talked to Vlad
today yeah it's generous yes we did it
he he films one of the projects that
James and I did together it was a like a
performance art piece that I did at NYU
with him and with a couple other people
and so he did that and then he asked me
to act in his short film that he was
making and then you know I sort of I
started talking to James about Vlad and
like how cool I thought that was and how
nice flat is Jace is like hey why don't
you guys were coming together so that's
so that's how that happened oh very cool
and yeah we talked to Vlad and we asked
him like where would you and mean
you know discuss the the flushing out of
the sort of the scripts and everything
and he said you guys met around and
y-you and you find little spots and yeah
we said we'd go to like you know the
various coffee shops around NYU and we
just spend like hours there talking
making fun of each other